e já está valendo
é comigo mesmo uma fui boa tarde minha
amiga estou aqui essa daqui de casa para
falar com você e pedir
é você que me deixa entrar na sua casa
essa tarde maravilhosa ver com a gente
[Música]
é que tá começando
é apenas outra live aí tá aí na hashtag
você pode usar o twitter hashtag outra
live aí quando as pessoas falaram que
ele vier falar de doidos
e aí
e eu tô escutando o barulho dos pássaros
e agora sim só para dar o pote da luz ii
e mostra esse pôr do sol que eu tentei
mostrar para as pessoas a minha vista de
casa todo dia
e já tá então galera é
ah tá entrando não começou a
o poder levantar o apresentador de
televisão você meu amigo você minha
amiga vem agora se divertir brincar um
pouquinho a vizinha ali acho que estão
aí obrigado viu estou com uma cara de
pecador aqui na minha frente pode baixar
o som aí meu amigo
a baixar exatamente antigamente eles
fazer aquele negocinho que ia descer na
música devagar né agora para no meio da
música e ninguém fica sabendo mais de
nada mas tamo junto obrigado a vizinha
que tá ali na frente a minha única
plateia é a minha vizinha que ali na
frente uma honra para você ter comprado
a casa de frente quando eu show viu
nós tamo junto
o rosto e você tem que mora aí em olha
só quando dona descobrir vamos lá galera
muito obrigado você está assistindo aqui
agora você pode usar a hashtag outra
live aí que a gente vai fazer muita
brincadeira muita besteira nada
praticamente né gente só fez isso aqui
quer fazer uma live bacana a galera fez
e é muitas lives ultimamente tá todo
mundo aqui devidamente de máscara com
suas máscaras no rosto ó todo mundo ali
ó usando suas máscaras vinhos que a
propósito essa máscara aí revelou uma
outra coisa do brasileiro que é uma
coisa importante que a gente tem que
falar agora
e a gente precisa falar sobre o tamanho
da orelha do brasileiro porque a gente
viu pela armas que aqui nós não temos as
orelhas iguais
e todo mundo uma hora fica folgado
demais outro hora ficar apertado demais
outra hora puxa a orelha das pessoas
está constrangendo a galera então vamos
fazer a associação dos urêa sair do
brasil tá bom todo mundo vamos começar a
lua aqui tá comigo meu parceiro luan
murilo murilo e toca guitarra sem sair
sensacionalmente já tocou guitarra com o
menino com o edson mais leves ué tô
naquele pique alguma diferente é o
grande ícone mundial da guitarra é tô
maconha onde você pode perguntar aí
pesquisar para todo mundo né opa chegou
aqui mas inquilina como quem não quer
nada né já sabe como é que é né já já
vivi na paz ninguém amarra no pé de
manga né
o cachorro lá no piauí no interior você
só sabe que tem os três dias depois faz
raiva eu tava comida para o cachorro no
pé de manga eu falo vale tem cachorro
aqui nessa casa você não entra nem
contato esse aqui não esses aqui olha
chega para aqueles fico fazendo de conta
que não existe a sozinho em casa mora em
casa aqui ai meu deus que bonitinha hein
oi amor aqui para começar vamos baixa aí
a cabecinha pode aqui a cabecinha aqui
pera aí abaixa a cabecinha vamos lá meu
deus abençoa lá de hoje na orando orando
orando pensou a live hoje não vamos lá
vou morar não pode parar de oração deus
abençoe você tá já falta a escola
dominical e agora
e vai lá deixa o pai começar aqui a
nossa brincadeirinha já tô tomando uma
desde cedo né não pode tomar no pode
beber porque diz que vai logo preso
então eu não quero confusão para mim
muito menos em quarentena que já tem
confusão demais na minha vida vamos
começar luan você tá feliz tô feliz
demais tá feliz tá aqui fazendo cara
trabalhar né cara é top de meu irmão eu
não aguentava mais fazer as coisas só
para mim que você fica criando só para
sua cabeça você vai explodir causando
sozinho dentro de casa contando que você
queira mais feliz que a gente vai
esbanjar aqui a nossa criatividade para
galera vai a primeira é
eu queria convidar todo mundo tá pra
assistir você pai você mãe pode assistir
a moça que tá ali pode meus vizinhos
aqui não se incomodar em um barulho pode
tá assistindo todo mundo você que é de
sp tá que hoje eu tô morando em são
paulo galera aqui ó fumar um narga
galera falou assim oh mano fumar um
narga só escuto isso aqui em são paulo
todo mundo aqui em são paulo é uma boa
pela fumaça que deus me livre sou do
nada bota a mão no bolso puxa o negócio
folgar é o maior do mundo do que é
bolinha e eu avatar vai empurrando
bolinha e não sei que sabe tudo viu
galera aqui de são paulo gosta de fumar
daqui a pouco ela é bem na reta aqui tá
aí aí vamos lá vamos lá começar você vai
conversar nós vamos lá já arrumei um
pouquinho bora tocar vou fazer uma
nostalgia madalena fica porque a minha
primeira a minha primeira aqui estourou
divisor de águas na minha vida foi o que
mudou tudo na minha carreira né foi
quando eu comecei
o mapa trabalhar com comédia foi quando
eu fiz essa paródia aqui alô vó tô
reprovado quem é das antigas vai
entender vai conhecer quem não é das
antigas vai ser mesmo que tá conhecendo
a pinta na perna da angélica é legal é
bacana você vai curtir vamos lá que tem
jeito para chamar nega ela já tá
começando se o que é isso da tua perna
você não sabe nada a galera vai lá fora
da angélica que é isso aí na tua perna
em é isso o menininho de 2 dias detox
vamos lá vai lá não
nós vamos fazer essa comida ali vai
colocar leite aqui que é muito antigo
mandei o que tô ligando 10 viu o luan
santana canta meteoro
e vai até aquela outra né gente olha ai
carnaval foto reprovado vó tô reprovado
por nota ruim eu tô lascado vó tô
reprovado vó tô reprovado vó tô
preocupado com ele para o fabiano foi
foi minha avó ela me beijava
não saia de casa aí é para feira
trabalhar deixar desligado para não
filho não vou entrar pode se esconde da
minha avó do pilar que esse livro entrar
no face é melhor sair adoidado para no
google pesquisar frase de caiu leve a
mesma no meu mural já postar de manhã
cedo não queria saber era acordar e no
face ficar começava a tirar foto da
louca ajeitado no photoshop para
entender eu gosto assim de semana fazer
o pé e na escola resultado vou pegar bem
na hora minha avó foi me ligar era tão
chorando que nem deu para escutar a loba
borra tropa o motor é prova botou é
prova de nota ruim eu tô lascando vó tô
reprovado vó tô reprovado vó tô
reprovado e o facebook é ocupado vamos
lá
a nova começar só para esquentar só para
lembrar eu gaguejo e realeza porque eu
tô depositar eu já falei para o menino
aqui o negócio meu não é live
o meu negócio é gravação porque quando
eu começo negócio de live aí tudo que é
para prestar ligeiro e rápido não presta
mais e todo mundo eu começo olhar para
galera começa ficar agoniada tá todo
mundo fazendo sinal para alguém assim ó
e aí vai sair outro aí eu fico aqui o
que é meu deus será que o povo não tá
escutando sabe que o povo não tá meu
irmão é loucura viu não gosto de live
não fale mais nada ao vivo é a última
vez que eu faço pois ao vivo essa daqui
e show normal
e sabe o que que acontece essas
histórias a música que misturou a
primeira oh alô vó tô reprovado
e ela nesse tempo eu tinha uns 17 e anda
assim para os 18 andar eu acho que dará
crente ainda e aí eu eu tinha muita
vontade de fazer alguma coisa artística
que eu assistir assistir o harry potter
o filme do harry potter e ficava
impressionado com um rapazinho que fazer
o harry potter já era famoso carai eu
ficava assim não tem 7 anos já solta
poder o que eu pensava [ __ ] cara
certinho já solta poder tá precisa de
repouso tá assistindo aquela também esse
menino a menina pais podia o [ __ ]
bicho ela vai eu nada adianta também
o merdinha tentava mexer poder da mente
praticamente inútil nada conseguir na
oração valendo é pesada chorando e essa
eu consegui mas o resto mais nada e aí
eu tinha vontade muito estrelar de fazer
o negócio né foi aí quando eu fui para
pela primeira vez eu vi o mar com meu
pai e minha mãe cheguei de noite no
macho aqui de noite no marca tudo escuro
eu não tive paciência de esperar o dia
amanhecer para ir no mar foi lá no mato
botar os pés para sentir povo de deus
peça lá mas você sente que ficar me
sentindo mata mesmo quero ver não mas
vou sentir eu passei por teus pé ei
carai água do mar de noite aí mas de
noite não vi sempre assim muito ansioso
né sempre assim muito ansioso e aí na
volta eu tava escutando uma paródia com
tirulipa fez tirulipa fez uma paródia
era outro parou de muito antigo também e
aí pela paródia dele eu me inspirei um
pouquinho assim e comecei a
e a escrever a paródia na volta para
casa chegando em casa paródia pronta
botei o celularzinho na na cama já tinha
noção zinho de acústica também já sabia
que que quando você achou já sabia que
quando você bota ali no guarda-roupa não
negocinho acostuma espuminha fica mais
legal fica mais bacana botei para gravar
deu o play chamei meus amigos tudo mudou
a partir daí meu irmão burro pensava que
eu ia para eliana não fui pensava que eu
ia para o faustão nunca vi o faustão na
minha vida até hoje eu não vi o faustão
o arrependimento morrer ele não vê o
faustão você não tem o faustão nunca vi
todo mundo rapaz não faltam é isso
aquilo é grandão parece um sorvete de eu
nunca vi queria ver para ver como é que
é realmente aí fiz essa daí né então eu
tinha essa infância meio daquele jeito
ali meio parar detalhe começou a mudar
as coisas começaram a mudar nessa época
eu morava com a minha vó lá não tinha
energia lá não tinha água não tinha
enfim vizinho 5 km de distância
e convencê-los praticamente fica ali
enrolando enrolando até alguém chegar
desembolar que senão nada vai acontecer
não tem nem condição e aí beleza
e lá de um radinho de pilha pílula na
época eu falava pílula hoje eu já mandei
ele falar contigo mas era pílula e aí eu
eu ele é a minha vó vó tava de
manhãzinha cedo e tocava muito três
cantor passar ter noção só para vocês
ter nossa você tá assistindo em casa tem
noção da vida que eu tinha do que que eu
pensava de onde eu podia ir com o meu
pensamento né até onde que tinha um
limite para poder dizer até onde eu vou
com meu pensamento
eu tocava estourado estourado estourado
na rádio lá pepe moreno
o michael jackson
o e felipe dylon
o ou seja eu na minha cabeça de um
menino de 8 anos no interior que não
tinha acesso a [ __ ] nenhuma o michael
jackson felipe dylon e o pepe moreno
tava brigando para ver quem era o melhor
do mundo de música era isso que eu
pensava tocava três vezes até por ele
diga aí pepe moreno ganhou do michael
jackson hoje tô me dá piripiri pé
direito nós terminar isso é começar de
banho em bairro de caraca meu pepe
moreno ganhou de novo ou seja o pepe
moreno me ensinou a ser quem eu sou hoje
por que eu me inspirei do pepe moreno
viu pepe moreno ganhado michael jackson
felipe dylon também estourados a musa do
verão ela não vamos colocar essa é
a verdade dói mesmo cê tirei a traficar
de areia são é melhor que meu deus
tomara né
e eu sonhei dançando sabor da água na
boca é a musa do verão calor no coração
para tanta chance de calma já falei para
[Música]
você tirei a tropical vestida de areia e
sal faz brilhar reflete uma azul no teu
corpo quase nu um swing da [ __ ]
dançando nas ondas meu meu deus sabor da
água na boca
quem é a musa do verão calor no coração
o fogo do teu beijo traz alucinação musa
do verão ardente sensação 40 graus de
sonho de desejo e paixão
é usado verão 1
e se olhar gotas de cristal ilumine no
litoral a regra para como é bom te amar
no swing da cor dançando nas ondas do
teu mel teu sabor da água na boca é a
musa do verão calor no coração o povo do
teu beijo traz alucinação musa do verão
a gente tentação 40 graus de sonho de
desejo e paixão nos a do verão foi do
nada demais
a babá
oi dá para me ajudar para botar no
computador ó tá nessa aqui andré tá
nessa para mim primeiro você achou
regina regina vem eu gosto de nome de
cachorro de gente que vê os vizinho
pensa que as pessoas que moram comigo
são todas doida eu falo regina dessa vez
toada de cima desse sofá aí galera fica
meu deus do céu que a regina tá louca
regina atrás do muro
eu tô cai aí diabo as pessoas ficam
vindo as outras vizinhas entendeu porque
você sempre deixa dizer aqui também é
doação aqui né só [ __ ] não viu aqui
também tem que doar a combater o
convívio quase que eu digo do apocalipse
lá não ele não precisa de ajuda ele
precisa de derrota então dois para gente
aqui ó só para você saber eu tô fazendo
uma campanha esses dias tá eu tô
recebendo um cachê eu já tô pegando esse
cachê inteiro e doando agora neste
momento
e aí
eu não sei se for comemoração das araras
estão rindo da minha cara mas eu tô
doando agora 100 mil reais para começar
aqui 100.000 para começar a galera mas
você pode mais isso e aquilo não quero
saber o que é que você acha 100 mil tô
começando agora e eu quero ouvir
ligações aqui dos meus amigos eu tenho
um amigo que tem dinheiro porque eu sei
porque viaja para longe eu sei quanto é
que custa você me fala que eu pergunto
quanto foi eu perguntei foi uma
pancadinha não só para viagem aí é o que
ela fala o valor eu fico sabendo posso
dizer se eu vou não precisa itinerário
ou vou para o mais longe né do lado
avesso do lado também a mesma coisa
oi e a menor valor e aí eu queria falar
o seguinte estou começando agora eu
quero ouvir ligações aqui do meu celular
de pessoa dizendo assim todo ano tanto
todo ano tanto quero tanto a gente sair
daqui com duas são eu adoro eu apoio o
like é sensacional mas o dinheiro vai
ajudar as pessoas nessa pandemia vamos
lá até alguém doando alguma coisa só de
e
15 toneladas de alimentos nós já
começamos aqui o start com 100 mil e 5
tonelada
a sodiê salgados essa é a mesma só que
essa marca um sal né entendi só de tá do
ano 5 toneladas o dia salgado que a
mesma só que salgado agora esse é o doce
que se não fica meio e sono né mistura
de doce com salgado é soro então ea
top-oca lopes
a 500 kg de tapioca tapioca 500 kg tá
bom porque rede tudo que você bota
tapioca rede fica melhor tá ficando de
noite hein tá ficando a nossa iluminação
vai já começar tudo que a gente tentou
gastar dinheiro aqui é economizar com
vocês eu tô economia olha aí quem tá
empurrando pode mostrar quem tá
empurrando ele tá empurrando o trevor aí
ó olha aqui para falar vir aqui ver aqui
olha aqui ele tá empurrando o trevor
porque o seguinte tem uma câmera atrás
do rapaz que tá no prédio e é muito
conveniente um rapaz grande fica
baixando toda hora que os anos como ele
está fazendo eu perguntei o rapaz quanto
é que ele cobrava o cara não vou ficar
me rebaixando não eu cobro 200 eu falei
para espera ainda fui lá no manoel falei
manoel tenho 75 manda na hora patrão
pronto deu certinho o dinheiro que eu
tinha porque eu não ando com dinheiro
entendeu uma pessoa que ganha dinheiro
assim eu não mando o dinheiro não ando
com o cartão tinha 75 do bolso na hora
paguei sem na dependência de emprego tá
tudo certo aqui
e vamos embora a bomba quer deixar
já chegou
o mãe a testando aqui eu falei meu forte
não é live lá no netflix é gravado tá
tudo lá você pode ir lá assistir adulto
whindersson nunes tem meu show
sensacional proparoxítona aqui também é
muito bom olha aí ó tá bom ó
oi pode falar
se você consegue aumentar um pouco aí
para nada
oi oi madalena ela tá assistindo aí
tu tá assistindo aí galera
e eu tenho como saber tô só aqui só
daqui mesmo tá saindo aí ó
o canal play vai
g1
a mesa ainda bem do caixa tá tomando
cerveja foi assim mim se eu te conheci
foi assim foi no risca faca que eu te
conheci dançando enchendo a cara fazendo
farra tô nem aí foi no ska faca que eu
te conheci
eu tô passando mexendo a cara fazendo
farra tô nem aí meu amigo pepe moreno um
abraço para você e você foi inspiração
para mim eu tenho que falar olha que
entender as crianças obrigado menina que
o seu pai está reclamando do barulho
causado por ele lá amanda não foi bom
demais o que foi o erro tempo ali foi
feito dele
tu tá doida é porque a gente tentou
fazer as músicas diferentes mas em cima
da hora assim mesmo
fala 185 mil pessoas online ao vivo
agora meu amigo tá doido vai lá
ei ei bota uma caneca de chá para mim
por favor tem um solo antes pô tô
tomando o mesmo chá do tirulipa ainda eu
tirulipa é o perigo que aquilo câmera
fica andando aqui direto se ele mija
aqui perigoso rapaz escorregar caipira
né beijo tulipa te amo irmão tô com
saudade de você meu deus essa quarentena
mas você tá ficando louco todo mundo né
essa mesmo de novo nego a outra uma
outra vamos outra vamos avançar quer que
o pessoal tá comentando no twitter e
olha para mim alguma coisa do twitter e
me diz aí égua meu irmão todos os
famosos tem as coisas tudo direitinho só
eu que essa [ __ ] aqui não funciona dá
o play aqui não vai não adianta de cadê
o twitter não tem a tela não tem ninguém
cuida de mim é
eu tô brincando é gratidão é só sempre
gratidão é só drama mesmo olha lá para
ele jardim vamos qual agora eu faço
drama mesmo porque
o que é bom né cara
e eu posso também né outono estado o
e ai ai galera houve um tempo na minha
vida que eu fui um cantor tinho eu era
um uma espécie de de um tiago iorc que
não funcionou alguns não funcionaram ato
tiago iorc teve uns que não deram certo
e eu eu era assim eu já tentei me
arrumar muito tempo sabe me atentei me
arrumar mas eu sou uma coisa difícil sou
um caso difícil as pessoas olha eu ponho
você fala eu não sei se ele é feio você
é bonito isso é o pior
e quando fala é feio você tem a certeza
feio ai eu sou feio você sabe o que é o
problema agora enquanto uns gostam
outros não gosta deus que quer mas o
outro não quer não adianta eu me
considero um celta no céu tinha
reformado entendeu tô brumadinho tá
cromadinho direitinho tá limpando o
câmbio está todo novo recauchutou olha
dentro tá ok entendeu tem até que ele um
cheiro do da cinza de cigarro já tá lá
longe lá longe você quase não tá
sentindo mais assim quase não tá
sentindo mais entendeu mas mesmo com
kadron mesmo com rodas
esse é um celta no final das contas
chassi é o mesmo mesmo número tá escrito
ali do gene eu olho para o chassi do meu
pai eu sei o meu já sei entendeu eu olho
para minha mãe olha o meu pé
esse é um tomar água da minha mãe souber
ela me deu a única mágoa que eu tenho da
minha mãe é o pé eu boto aqui o preto
recauchutagem no máximo para poder não
dá para mostrar aqui
um porém
e eu tinha muitos fãs e tinha muitas
músicas muitas musiquinhas legais as
pessoas adoravam tem uma que até até 17
milhões de visualizações que uma música
chama tão linda eu tenho aí tem a você
que é meu fã da antiga a você que é meu
fã lá de 2012 2011 2012 nostalgia até
para mim porque eu não cantava lá nem
lembrava dessa música direito agora vou
até letra para poder fazer leite vamos
lá que era bem antigo e aí ó
olá olá
e aí
a web abraço meu amigo companheiro lá de
fortaleza saudade meu amigo
é difícil
e outra você de novo vou dar um beijo
ó tá vendo até as partes aqui ó já
esconder ho.es tava na área de trabalho
o cara que ele cava músicas live para o
nome da pasta músicas live
me dá o ente música mas agora não tem
mais a música simplesmente ela foi para
longe o mais longe possível para ele
procurar aí então reclama não tá é
contigo sou eu já começa agora não a
gente fez para lembrar também a gente a
gente vai fazer o seguinte a gente tá
tentando fazer aqui uma mudança nas
músicas para você também tem uma
nostalgia sem também lembrarem das
músicas antiga que a gente fazer meio
falamansa assim sabe quer ver bota aí
bota aí ela já começa no doação quero
ouvir aqui no meu celular agora enquanto
eu tiver cantando aqui agora eu quero
doação tá parecendo o estoque convido na
tela lá da stop dois aqui no qr code por
favor qualquer quantia você vai ajudar
muito vamos fazer aqui tentar fazer um
falando assim ah legal para você com a
música minha e vamos embora lá
a menina do sorriso esse teu jeito que
menina que me faz arrepiar as madrugadas
são demais perfeito estado sky você uma
longe mesmo a pena menos celular e eu
vou depender de mim eu vou envolver meu
coração ta doendo então deixa de
escrever veja olha que me faz bem é você
então não fique chateada quando eu pedir
para ficar mais um pouco aqui no chat
comigo de madrugada tudo isso porque eu
quero te ver bem o teu sorriso que me
faz feliz
o que eu não sou essas coisas mas eu
posso ser o cara que sempre feliz e o
que só um rapaz e um boné para trás sem
qualidade ainda fiz essa letra para te
alegrar eu quero eles não quero ver
chorar com a menina que eu acho linda
tão linda tô te querendo demais eu não
vou dar para trás vagalume é um carai eu
vou atrás até de onça para poder te dar
um
se sentirem caraca serviu
o meu outro aí ó tenho palhacinho aí ó
manel' sobe divulgar doppler para não
errar vamos fazer logo várias as antigas
aqui para relembrar quem tiver quem
foram as antigas quem não for tá
lembrando música de quando eu era
adolescente tá essas músicas eu era
adolescente tá bom meu amigo vamos
embora mas o chá de boldo tirulipa
se você gostar na tela qr code na pele
nesse momento para você fazer a sua
doação daí da sua casa tá assistindo com
seu pai com a sua mãe perturbe você
perturba por um lanche você perturba por
um sanduíche por um pedido né na rap
agora se você quiser você pode pedirem
rappi está aqui ó nosso patrocinador
oficial deste evento fazendo tudo que
acontecer estrutura de ponta luzes
compradas trilho caro botão aqui para
funcionar manel nunca empurrou tanto e
puxou o negócio da vida dele vai puxar
até o carai porque foi caro viu vamos
embora já já vai ficar de noite essa luz
vão ficar sensacionais vai ser muito
massa tem o bracinho aí acorda sua vale
assim essa daqui também machucou os
corações dos adolescentes de 11 anos
oi eita menina que ele tava no show e
fazer a fila zona o coelho é só gritando
no no hotel e eu o meu deus a fama está
me afligindo me deixem dormir mais lento
lá no ligam vamos lá na vó papai botar
nos carro limpador de vidro jogando
menino para o lado e
e tu é doido eu era [ __ ] demais
loucura loucura porque os meus fãs hoje
eles mudaram os meus fãs são mais velhos
de verdade realmente hoje são mais
velhos mas antigamente era mais novo
tinha essa gritaria se essa loucura esse
negócio hoje não hoje a galera enfim a
galera deseja coisas boas gosta de foto
ela gosta muito de tirar foto
e todo mundo sempre perdi muita foto
entendeu e eu sou diferente porque as
pessoas me assistem ela já se sente meus
amigos já antes de chegar ela já me
conhece eu não conheço ela entendeu
quero conhecer não tô dizendo que eu
quero mas eu não conheço e aí como eu
não conheço a pessoa chega no intimidade
muito grande não é como fã do merlin
entendeu fã do merlin ele só quer foto
foi com os 31
e o fã do menino que foto ah não tava só
do narizão não quero ai eu não saiu do
bom né não não quero de boné a galera só
quer se fosse três junto para dizer que
a capa do cd eu não eu sozinho o pessoal
fique correndo atrás fica só doideira
entendendo eu já tá conversei com o do
meio decidiu de como é que vocês faz ele
espaço e se separa não quero só com de
bom não
e eu queria era tudo é tipo uma carta de
yu-gi-oh né galera tem que juntar eles
treino para ter o poder isso é o poder
de uma linda né e eu não vi todo só vim
você fala o meu linho ou amendoim
amelinha menina ovelhinha qualquer um
dos meninos ai eu me liga muita onda tá
que a gente que já ficar na porta do
motel ama
e tirar foto comigo está brincando a
porta do motel
eu cheguei no motel sempre baixar o
vídeo para mostrar identidade quando eu
baixei ouvido acaba é nada eu com a
pomba amolecer na hora assim porque você
olha para o seu fã diretamente do olho
dele não dá realmente para você manter
uma ereção sabe porque quando você vai
você vai no sentido mas o cara dizia ou
totalmente meu assunto aqui não é nada
eu pensei eu dançando eu pobre crochê
para mim entendeu ainda perguntou onde
era fazer o que ela toda quarta-feira eu
não quero ficar lá te esperando para
tirar foto 3 camareira na porta do
quarto esperando para tirar foto minha
vizinha e
e três camareira na porta do quarto
esperando aqui no lugar que você vai
para general não pode porque a dona
neide tá escutando encostado ali na
porta tu é doido mano é muita falta do
que fazer para falar a verdade falta do
que fazer a pessoa ficar um tempo
inteiro esperando a pessoa terminal
levar para tirar foto como é que ela ter
paciência de esperar dois minutos
inteiro eu saí do quarto não faço não
faz sentido isso realmente as pessoas
estão sem noções nos dias ai ai eu tenho
problema por foto não tô pagando o
bumerangue bumerangue que eu não gosto
porque ninguém sabe fazer é um
instrumento tá aí no instagram faz muito
tempo ninguém sabe fazer como era que
você
eu bati uma vez e ele grava e repete o
movimento eu preciso passar meia hora
assim não que a pessoa fica assim ó já
foi e esperando vou marant terminal 1
e quando é android quero ver o android
erro compasso do vídeo fica assim ó
o quê
o tempo é errado dá não mano é muita
[ __ ] vai ver que a lei da quis botar
aqui ó
a missa a palhacinha eu já está doendo
vai lá pede palco
a chegar foi 41 minutos e live se amor
que nasceu em mim parece até coisa de
filme mas não é é assim ó
eu resgato o que fez meu coração bater
de um jeito diferente dentro talvez seja
o jeito que você joga o cabelo o jeito
que você sorri quando eu tô perto eu não
sei seu jeito de você glam minha eu só
sei que é você que eu quero
e não é faz assim você daí e eu daqui te
amamos por wi-fi não é fácil assim não
vai e eu daqui eu sinto uma vontade de
largar tudo e correr para e deixa eu
olhar para você um pouco você ficar tão
linda com esse batom deixa eu saber se o
teu lábio é mas eu e saber se o teu
beijo é tão bom fico tão feliz quando
você rir de mim seca no meio difícil de
entender
olá eu sou só olha assim eu querendo
alguém para fazer esse alguém que eu
quero é você se ri de mim sei que é meio
difícil de te ver eu sou são pode assim
querendo alguém para fazer esse alguém
que eu quero é você eu quero é você
há muito tempo pelo trocar essa massa aí
[Música]
alguém aí tá doando alguma coisa para
mim
oi para mim não para as pessoas
tá sim olha a luz aí mudando em já já
vai entrar calma calma não esquece
deixar seu like também aí e usar a tag
no twitter outra live aí
e ai ai tem um beijo que eu nunca te dei
vez que eu nunca te dei outra música
muito antiga que eu tinha feito para uma
menina que eu me apaixonei por quê
é porque não tem um adolescente né para
dar você se apaixona eu me apaixonei por
ela nunca conheci essa menina fiz uma
música para ela e
a música tem até outro sentido hoje né
porque nem lembro mais como era o rosto
de que eu me inspirei para poder fazer a
música mas
eu vou pegar em o beijo que eu nunca te
dei prometo ainda vou te dar no dia que
eu te encontrar se eu vou te encontrar
não sei prometeu vou te procurar por
todo lugar que eu passar para te trazer
de volta para o lugar onde você não veio
pra saciar o meu anjo senhor de poder te
tocar e quando entra fecha a porta não
te importa como eu tô meio vem acredito
que você dê you
e agora eu vou poder te beijar o peito
que não tá aqui tem como é que tá na
cidade eu te encontro branco o oi oi eu
vou te encontrar tão ser prometeu vou te
procurar o do lugar que eu passar o
peito aqui trazer de volta no lugar onde
você não meio para saciar o meu seio de
poder te tocar do ar e quando entra
fecha a porta não te importa como eu tô
feio vem acredito que você leio agora eu
vou poder te beijar e o
a cat nikki prometo aqui da pode dar um
dia que eu te encontrar ou doido eu vou
te encontrar tão sei tu prometeu vou te
procurar um todo lugar que eu passar eu
já te fiz não usei o amorzinho da
guitarra vamo lilo é bonito demais né
não é uma coisa que gosta de música hora
dessa em casa tá meu deus olha isso vou
deixar mais tempo que comanda aqui
[Música]
talvez você nunca
e aí lá vai parar mais atenção hoje é
isso aí acaba não tem o finalzinho da
final tem pena guitarrista minha amiga
igual a classe ter onde chega essa se
amostra logo na cabeça dele é isso aí
mesmo essa essa aqui é uma das minhas
preferidas tá é uma das preferidas
porque eu acho ela muito bonita mesmo
assim tocante eu acho ela bonita de
verdade ela eu acho que ela
e eu tava inspirado nesse dia vamos lá
chama overdose de você para mim é uma
das minhas preferidas
e vai lá
é aquela versão maravilhosa qual tem não
tem aí quer ir quer ir só no só só na
guitarrinha velentin ajudo você lá
nós vamos fazer só guitarrinha voz
violão tem como desligar uma luz para
deixar assim a gente o clima bem legal
gostosinho bacana para quem tiver em
casa sofrer também tem é só dar o clique
zinho aqui nessas luzinhas vai fazer né
tá bem aqui sempre demora um pouco nunca
é na hora certa porque tem esse problema
de dinheiro está na live se fosse a
eliana sentada aqui celso portiolli ou
não sei todos dão certo eles estão play
funciona até o final mas não é você sou
eu vocês entenderem sou eu onde eu vou
entrar as a luz não pegar as o play na
dar azo tô nem aí por isso que é bom se
você estiver doando aí a rappi que vai
patrocina mas se você tiver olha aí
ligou achar batman já pode tá
e bota um dó não fa mi menor ré
em lá menor com baixo em oitava fila
enorme be lgbt bota bota sol e disse
quem me faz querer acorda bota botão
zinho
oi turu bom tempo essa noite meu amigo
minha amiga você que está hoje na sua
casa sofrendo
[Música]
tô sofrendo por algum motivo
o que me desse momento você abrir seu
coração entendesse que dá para amar de
qualquer forma
eu quero ver vamos lá
o pênis é esse que me faz querer é a
corda do teu lado
o time faz até esquecer meu coração que
me faz um cara querendo mais parar de te
olhar me descontrola é você é
e para que eu sempre tente mês que vá da
cura para ver se eu posso te encontrar
em qualquer rua para esse vício eu
sempre alimentar e nunca acabar porque
eu posso até me afastar o povo mas esse
vídeo faz voltar de novo volta logo e eu
te vejo para matar meu desejo que você
sabe que eu amo você então mais de dois
mil quilômetros para te ver só para
sentir o gosto do teu beijo então me faz
entender
é porque eu sou viciado no teu beijo na
tua voz porque todo dia você faz eu
querer te beijar de novo porque o seu
bom dia faz o meu coração dispara sem
querer me faz entender não me faz
entender porque eu ando louco apaixonado
doido para te ver quanto mais a gente se
encontra mais você me faz querer eu
quero ter uma overdose de você é
e aí
e aí chamou chamou não retornou porque
vai
e eu errei ali pelo menos até agora aqui
um pouco mas esse vício vai voltar de
novo volta logo e eu te vejo eu matar
meu desejo do dia cê sabe que eu amo
você para te ver só para sentir o gosto
do teu beijo então me faz entender
é porque eu sou viciado no teu beijo na
tua vó de no teu corpo porque todo dia
você faz eu querer dinho beijar de novo
eu coloquei o seu mundinho faz um meu
coração dispara não sem querer então me
faz entender eu ando louco apaixonado tô
doido para te ver quanto mais a gente se
encontra mais você me foi querer eu
quero ter ser uma dor 12 de você
[Aplausos]
e tocou os corações esse mesmo clima vai
me dar do zero vai
15 passeios eita
é só que essa daqui que nós
10 até aqui tem aí velho tomate aí ó
cometer outro chamado 10 essa outra
chama do zero né é uma uma música também
muito antiga que eu fiz
bom e eu gosto muito dela também
e eu vou trocar agora pra vocês a gente
fez uma versão zinha que vai ver se
vocês gostam também tá bom
e goleou a leonor seixas fala em
g1
e aí ó
oi oi
em casa ela vai me dizer que hora que eu
entro eu não sei né não vai dar certo
[Música]
agora vem meu melhor é assim em tudo é
do jeito que a gente quer eu dei o meu
melhor não foi um qualquer mas acho que
eu deixei faltar água a rir prática
também não sei não é você que manda no
seu coração amei tudo que eu queria era
te ver sorrir e
e se você quiser
e eu thomé surdo lado tá tudo que eu
mais ser uma chance de consertar se você
quiser que eu espero espero para tv
jardim de mim deitado no seu sofá tá bom
então vamos lá que tá outra live aí em
primeiro do twitter agora neste momento
[Música]
o fato do
é feio foi uma gentileza de deus pronto
ele é altamente talentoso é engraçado
para caramba toca quase todos os
instrumentos possíveis plantamos se
fosse bonito seria uma [ __ ] de uma
sacanagem cara vez que tá me ajudando ai
ai vamos de terapia quando eu vi que
começaram a vencedores minha vida tá
igual a live do windows nada dá certo
mas continua engraçado tá com paulo
vamos lá vamos colocar uma legal aqui ó
eu prometo hoje apesar da gente tá
fazendo a live engraçado como disse o
rapaz do twitter aqui você pode tentar
outra live aí qualquer coisa eu vou
estar interagindo com vocês aqui mas a
gente tá passando por um momento que a
gente tá com saudade
e quem tá com saudades a cara eu tô aqui
em são paulo são paulo é um local que é
o epicentro aí que tá dando muita merda
dessa pandemia aí e e o meu pai tá no
piauí minha família tá no piauí e a
gente tem que saudade cara eu acho que
eu tenho certeza que muitas pessoas que
moram fora de e não mora em suas casas
hoje né tem saudade os seus parentes e
tudo mais e eu tenho muita saudade do
nordeste cara sabe eu tenho muita
saudade eu não sou um cara que fica ai
brigando por isso o brigando por aquilo
não adianta ninguém vai querer ninguém
vai conseguir me mudar a pessoa que eu
sou quando eu sair lá do piauí é o mesmo
que eu sou hoje por isso que a minha
vida é desse jeito e dá certo entendeu
dá certo é desse jeito mas eu tenho
saudade demais do nordeste eu gosto
demais cara [ __ ] que pariu
oi tá de chorar saudade
e aí
tá bom então do aí para passar logo isso
aí cara
e apesar de tudo
o filme vamos fazer sabe qual é
a ave maria sertanejo toque para gente
vamos na
a novela 11 né tá dizendo né ela vai
volta de novo é
e no chão
[Música]
a pesquisa assunto sua outro um tom aa
a minha é muito bom quando o cabo ajuda
o cara que toca com o olho assim você
que já tô com a igreja nem sabe como é
que as coisas o irmãozinho não quero nem
saber eu quero no tempo está com cristo
toque só vou imitar teu irmão da igreja
como é que ele chega eu quero estar com
cristo onde a luta se trava do lance
imprevisto todos te encontrar até que eu
possa ser agora se alegre tudo na vida
de deus não tem como
e não dá então eu vou no olho aqui além
disso por isso o cara que toca na igreja
ainda tem a senhora da palma desconecta
porque tem o cara eu quero estar com
cristo e uma senhora aqui ó
[Música]
bom então vamos no olho aqui eu falei
que eu tocar na igreja meu amigo tu é
doido quando é isso é a frustração total
que é você deixar o a banda todinha
sentar aí o carro traz o playback a
banda todinha o one two three já conhece
a música do cantor o cantor cd queen um
é o dedo do dvd de estava parado na
igreja o caminho é uma banda que
acompanha o playback ainda mesmo com
playback vontade de tocar né vai lá vai
lá
há 30 anos todos os nordestinos aí no lá
quando bate tenha 6 horas e joelhos ou
bruxão o céu sertanejo presa assunto sua
oração
a a b c e d maria pia mãe
e eu jesus to the for sair for argen
para carregar a nossa cru digo para
poder montar vai no bar até 6 horas de
joelhos sobre o chão o céu sertanejo rei
assunto sua oração
e a abrir uma pinha mãe de deus jesus
[Aplausos]
nos dê força e coragem para carregar a
forma nossa cruz
nós tamo junto dessas doações que vocês
estão fazendo isso ajudando muito para a
gente tá pra galera de onde eu moro
também que lá no nordeste olha vocês as
discussãozinha de twitter de vocês são
muito em rio de janeiro e são paulo
vocês presta atenção no brasil inteiro
que o brasil é grande hein vai ficar
nessa brotar essa [ __ ] zinho aqui de
rio são paulo aqui ó as casas nordeste
pobre lá é 5 km uma da outra pessoa olha
como eu tava falando da merda ninguém
ficar nem sabendo então cesta básica que
a gente vai doar com esse dinheiro que a
gente arrecada hoje vai ajudar para
[ __ ] muita gente não esqueça disso
você tá salvando vidas tá bom tamo junto
lembrando das músicas de adolescente que
eu fazia tem uma música nova também que
eu fiz quando era mais adolescente essa
música você não me engana de 2013 mas é
uma música muito legal eu queria cantar
aqui pra vocês e que eu botar em cima do
microfone aqui para mim
e desliga no outro aqui tá
a equipe de bolo em
um talento aqui
e porquê
e eu também fiz ultimamente né
oi eita vamos ver aqui estão ninguém tá
dando a doação aqui
o primo rico mandou a foto da tela mas
não muda a doação aqui eu sou igual
marco feliciano eu digo a doação tem que
fazer eu cobre tela senha hein
e é quanto suas coleguinhas em cinco
meus coleguinhas do aro pois então agora
escola aqui tá doando 25 mil e eu eo
rico também eu sou malandro se tu deixar
eu tenho dinheiro teu mas é para as
pessoas são robin hood é o roubo dos
ricos para dar aos pobres
o primo rico agora tô aqui ao vivo botou
aqui arrebenta mas eu queria arrebentar
minha conta para poder doar mas pessoa
mas não tava me dando tá do jeito
começou a conta a parada a verdade tá
negativo que eu deixei né então vamos lá
vamos ver se tem mais alguém querendo
doar aqui vamos lá vamos ver e elton
vasconcelos lá de teresina está aqui no
whatsapp mandando um alô também mudou
bom mas se quiser o ataque continua
aberto aqui tá valendo funcionando
normalmente tá bom vamos lá aqui ó
o yuri marçal tá mandando um alô a todo
mundo aqui também diego jovino fortaleza
ordinária o gabriel oliveira recife
ordinário diogo ordinário maceió
ordinário natal ordinário a rede
ordinário está todo empezo assistindo a
gente aqui g souza também está
assistindo a gente aqui vamos embora
e aí
e lembrando que daqui a pouco tem live
do robson johnson qual são johnson está
fazendo uma live amanhã amanhã não hoje
que hora é robson 20 horas tem lá e de
stand-up são um tempinho legalzinho para
você curtir dá uma risadinha dentro da
sua casa na ideia você vai adorar tá bom
então vamos lá
e vamo lá
e qual vai ser pode me tão casseta lá do
posto vai lá nic megale compositora
desta música junto comigo
e lá de varginha belo horizonte nicole
megale um abraço para você a nossa
música já já está saindo nas plataformas
digitais você tem a é privilégio é não
sei se fosse gostar é privilégio não
gostar é o azar de assistir ao vivo
agora lá de londres sabe que tá
assistindo real-time bryan fritz está
assistindo lá de longe com a francisco e
o arnaldo e a minha sobrinha nua minha
sobrinha na minha minha afilhada né
padrinho é o que da pessoa é minha
sobrinha ela minha afilhada minha
afilhada que eu não sei também
e eu cresci chamando o padre padre mas
não sabia nem a função dele mas eu falar
para ir bença padrinho aí dá uma bênção
tchau às vezes coisa centavo é ótimo
padrinho eu acho que você tá ao garantir
você vai no padrinho mete a mão no bolso
acho que pode até chegar já meteram a
mão no bolso né
e vai dar play vamos lá agora tu estrada
seguiu provado posto mais você deixou
gosto da aventura que me apresentou eu
caminho é particular eu sei mas você me
levou contigo e eu me o amor que eu
nunca pensei te esperar hein morrendo de
vagarinho eu não estou construindo ninho
para consegui zerar vou usar o que é
claro que machuque a de rir gosto de nós
doido e puro na realidade que eu pensei
sua mira
a saudade mais bonita eu criei amei meu
tudo sobre respirar saudade eu já sei
decor é rotina tua falta preenchendo o
vazio ao meu redor do tempo é mais um
inimigo os números conspiram ao vivo
favor e
o que esperar é e morrendo de vagarinho
pastor construindo new para quando você
quiser pousar o que é claro macho que
arde gosto de nós dois furos na
realidade que eu pensei tua mirage aqui
saudade mais bonita eu fiquei sei que
sonhar eu suicídio lento me perdi da
saudade o esquecimento mas hoje é só o
primeiro dia do resto de nossas vidas e
o número de tururu vamos milho na
guitarra e você já fez a sua doação
é não meu whats está ligado aqui
é para me ligar aqui bryan fritz felipe
meu ex copiloto
o copiloto eu nunca pensei que eu
pudesse dizer isso um dia na minha vida
meu ex copiloto umas coisas que você não
e até hoje eu fico assim às vezes galera
bora de para onde tem um avião meu vixe
se pressionar o
e obrigado essa música logo logo está
com a plataforma bem bonitinha bem
feitinho ela é linda essa música adoro
essa música se você gostar de um like lá
essa daqui lula murilo mudou a minha
vida para sempre qual é a senha do wi-fi
qual é a senha do wi-fi foi uma música
que foi um divisor de águas na minha
vida eu agradeço muito aqui gabriel
oliveira pontes fez léo da jega danilo
para o display
e todo mundo canal posts vem sempre me
ajudou no início da minha carreira
sempre sempre sempre sempre sempre
esteve comigo e a gente fez a paródia
qual a senha do wi-fi cara eu juro por
deus que eu tava no banheiro tomando
banho
eu cantarolei qual é a senha do wi-fi
parei o banho na hora que eu tava que
quando eu cantarolei isso eu já sabia
que era cabeça boa para escara e aí eu
falei gabriel tem uma paródia e eu já
sei onde é que eu quero gravar porque eu
sempre achei o marco zero em recife com
a mais linda do mundo assim eu amo eu
amo ir lá eu vou sempre meio-dia porque
todo resistência e tem a cabeça certa
não vai no marco zero meio-dia porque é
faz mal até para organismo tu é doido
mas o vapor além sob acabou chega
borbulha prepara a pessoa por dentro é
possível fui lá só gravar essa cena eu
gastei r$800 no drone para levantar essa
[ __ ] desse dono eu usei igual carai
manda ele dar a volta em mim nem o sesi
mais mas manda ele filmar até acabar a
bateria que eu queria macho é só uma
cena tu só levanta me dá essa imagem no
cartão pô eu compro o teu cartão né
melhor não falei para ele passa comprar
o cartão ficar tem memória do cartão sd
um conto de devolve depois falei para
ele aí não há 800 conta daquela época
drone meu amigo drone é negócio da nasa
drone era coisa que
oi vó tu é doido para passa no interior
ali do piauí galera até faz culto depois
reza não sei chama meu irmão era daquela
época era pesada é o cara subiu lado
onde fez assim nós sensacional essa
música para mim mudou a minha vida
porque realmente foi onde eu tive que
fazer decisões não é nem porque eu
fiquei famoso depois disso que depois
disso eu comecei a aparecerem tv
aparecem rádio em tudo que eram teatro
fala muito fala demais né tem ninguém
para conversar luan hoje vocês estão
aqui eu tô adorando tem uma plateia tá
falando as coisas senão eu fico sozinho
eu faço sozinho dentro de casa viu vocês
entrar aqui eu tiver sozinho você vai
ficar e se assustando correr um
o final da barriga da marca já acabou os
aqui também
e olha que o mato e tá doando 30 tô
brincando brincadeira o meu deus você
também é tudo a sério qual é a senha do
wi-fi eu tive que fazer decisão volta a
assunto decisão você quer na sua casa
aqui também é motivacional faz uma uma
trilha sonora para poder ficar
motivacional tipo de igreja quando o
pastor tá falando
[Música]
e tem que ser um dói um tem que ser sol
e dó só que não sempre é
e quando eu fiz qual é a senha do wi-fi
e na época eu estava em uma campanha
publicitária e essa música esta paródia
poderia trabalhar em
e vai passar para guardar
e aí
vou mostrar aqui da também tá tudo não
fica assim eu fui aconselhado pelos meus
as pessoas que estavam me agenciando na
época não postar qual é a senha do wi-fi
só coisa que você não sabe sobre citação
na minha cabeça mas eu quero falar para
você eu sou uma pessoa normal igual a
você do jeito que eu tô agora do almoço
você me abraçar agora apertar muito
peida ser humano é biológico
o tempo você me aconselha não postar
essa para que ia me atrapalhar e mudou a
minha vida não quer dizer que você diz
assim ai mas vou sair de casa da droga
vai mudar a sua vida vai dar certo não
tem que ter noção da vida prestar
atenção
e onde você quer chegar e eu tinha noção
de eu queria chegar e eu sabia que
aquele ia me ajudar a
e amém amém
[Música]
me perdoe estou sentindo aqui a energia
mudando você que está assistindo aqui em
casa hoje qual é a senha do wi-fi pega o
meu sentimento quando eu criei ela não
que você pensou quando você assistiu
porque na época minha sacada foi essa
todo lugar que você chegava estava
começando a ter wi-fi quando tinha era o
diferencial então eu falei vou botar
isso numa paródia e vai estourar e estou
e deu certo você pode fazer isso também
vamos embora vai lá
o olá agora
e agora olá assim olá
e aí só vim dar uma passadinha que
saudade ainda ok seus pais adorei eu tô
meio inquieto deixa quieto eu não sei e
aí
em gostei aqui é tudo muito lindo seu
cachorro vou também mas vamos ao ponto
por favor lá em casa deu uma chuva eu
voltei a dor temor então me ajuda
é um pouquinho só vou tentar né
e qual é a senha do wi-fi eu juro eu não
aguento mais meus curro é que eu vou
mandar
[Música]
o prato tenho que postar qual é a senha
do wi-fi eu juro eu não aguento mais meu
como que eu vou mandar vem o que postar
por favor sou eu o meu trem já não
funciona então roteiro ainda para mim só
um pouco
é só um pouquinho e eu comprei outro
pacote mais acabo rapidinho a chegar lá
e de quem é é senhor me desculpe eu vou
gritar
em qual a filha do wi-fi eu juro eu não
aguento mais meus que eu vou mandar
escreve parado tenho que postar qual é a
senha do wi-fi eu juro eu não é o meu
[Música]
que eu vou abandonar tenho que posta por
favor continue vai conceder de ladinho
varia
e qual é a senha do wi-fi eu juro eu não
aguento bar mais meus como o é que eu
vou falar é
oi eita meu amigo tu é doido chega tenho
saudade da minha escola não
a saudade de escola fica saudade de casa
mas no interior eu gosto das coisas
interior
eu sou doido por interior cara velho
interior me apetece eu gosto de ficar
vendo vai começar tem nada tô aqui
dentro de casa parado não pode fazer
nada não
e eu posso viajar pra algum lugar não
alguém me responde essa essa essa coisa
tem um avião posso entrar dentro dele no
álcool gel banhar ele primeiro eu posso
lavar ele não rodo com álcool gel também
se der pode fazer isso
e eu perguntei se podia tipo pintar com
hidrocor o cara disse que não podia
falei comprei não essa [ __ ] não é que
eu comprei um negócio eu posso pintar
para sair o com ele
eu vim para minha casa tem problema seu
mas e aí mas não vai dar nada
é mas eu te perguntar ministério da
saúde ministério da saúde me responde ao
vivo eu posso para minha casa só falar
com meu pai
oi carai mano tô ficando louco em casa é
é bem saudade de casa meu amigo saudade
até de fazer prova do mimeógrafo
eu lembro mimeógrafo
o tênis all mimi olha foi na escola que
a professora fazer um negócio assim saia
com álcool cative de água a prova
se lembra aquilo ali era quando o pt viu
vô tava na nas provas para embeber das
crianças as crianças ficaram de verdade
isso é eu vi
é amanda é brincadeira é o morro ser
besta besta acho que é doido é besta a
criança queria ficar na recuperação às
vezes só para pegar outra dose mano
ele não é doido a pessoa não vira a
prova me bebo babando em cima da prova é
bom responder logo para cá dormir de
ressaca criança fará prova que ele
ressaca no outro dia que foi menino
prova de química ó uma coisa que falar
pra vocês eu gosto muito eu tenho
saudade do interior da sua que eu matei
a saudade é porque você pode sair
comprar uma coisinha assim na vendinha
né pertinho de casa sempre uma vez de
uma pessoa quer lá na nossa como é o
nome do senhor
o seu deca um abraço seu deck lá em
teresina entendeu era um cara que nós
sempre a falar sempre tem uma vendinha
ou mercadinho você consegue tudo fácil
só tem coisa que você precisa na hora
sardinha piadinho normal caderninho na
mão caderninho caderninho nem entre as
folhas os seus conhecidos amigos pé
interior lá os cara tem uma resposta
certa para tudo que é tem tem aperta aí
mais até em falta né
e como é que tem matar em falta não tem
eu tenho raiva grande assim ah tá tem na
segunda-feira tá chegando aí
segunda-feira mas é quarta quero jantar
agora como é que eu vou segunda-feira eu
vou esperar qualquer coisa segunda não
dá certo é muita onda viu
é mas se você quiser pedir rap em ó tá
ali ó dá um close ali meu câmera
a quebra ali ó rap rap está aí para você
vou ver aqui um negócio para você também
direitinho falar que para você
e ai ai ai ai ai meu cupom você pode
usar agora é o cupom vídeo pode usar tá
na tela pra galera tem na tela é
possível isso
é um cupom ir você pode meu amigo
comprar coisinhas com promoções cupom
wind o nome é windy do meu cupom quando
você for comprar lá no rappi
independente se tiver aparecendo na tela
ou não explicando bem facinho para você
se chegou lá se fizesse cupom de
desconto digita wind de mudo meu nome
tem tem h né w h e n the wind é o meu
cupom meu jovem você vai ser só alegrias
tá bem ok pode pedir qualquer coisa
exatamente farmácia e tal porque tem
gente que confunde um pouco e acho que é
só comida entendeu mas não é você pode
pedir coisas mais aleatórias pode pedir
um remédio você pode pedir um uma corda
no violão não pode uma escova de dente
tá precisando o negócio é essencial para
sua vida agora nesse momento não pode
faltar pede um rapidinho com cupom onde
eu tenho até um promoçãozinha para você
onde mora qual é a próxima aí
o lula murilo eu era muito era danado na
escola viu um dia eu só foi que
aconteceu agora tava brincando de jogar
casca de melancia quem conseguiu botar a
casca de melancia do outro lado do muro
aí eu peguei a caixa lancheira melancia
né é às vezes eles ficaram triste às
vezes creme cracker glicose o doce de
goiaba nas no organismo da criança de 6
anos o creme craque é desse tamanho o
doce da grossura de dor dedo aí ela é
praticamente corta um doce em três e
dividir para três crianças do golfo bom
dá para criança criança come ali enfim
aí tem dia que ele quer da fruta né é da
melancia e comendo a casca terminava com
minha casa todo mundo vamos ver que bota
no lado do muro começar a jogar batendo
vou jogar lá e bateu no muro lá vem o
whindersson nunes certamente nada dá
certo para mim quando eu que eu vou
tentar né
e que assim besta joguei não só passou
do mundo como ter uma mulher estendendo
a roupa pegou a casca de melancia na
festa da moema
eu corri para a sala sentei e fiquei lá
respirando porque o aluno o aluno ele
faz a médica e acho que ele vai passar
lá ele some ele dentro eu acho que
ninguém veio na cadeira assim ó
o cara vai correndo para dentro da sala
você tá logo na cadeirinha nas coisas
dele
ah tá esqueci de chegar em casa estava
mulher conversando olha é o seguinte eu
vi que foi ele tá cá meu amigo de dar em
três meninos meu jovem um isso nos levou
aqui é paga para torto ea direito vocês
quiserem eu fico contando vai ser surra
uma atrás da outra
e eu ainda meu minha mãe e
é um beijo valdenice um beijo e dobrando
estão em casa assistindo agora esta live
também vamos embora para da 8ª série
nós não vamos rap lord i
o rap lord rap lord por que é coisa de
criança porque é coisa de escola e
porque é difícil aqui esse eu tô me
enganando já tô melado então agora vai
ser a hora de testar se eu accurate tá
19 e as luzinhas aqui a tarde o luan
loja te mostrar tu não tá nem ligado eu
nem time falei eu nem te falei eu tô
aqui com o melhor celular do mundo da
xiaomi aqui está ele lindíssimo o preço
acessível para todo mundo tem a promoção
aí o link está na descrição aqui deixa
lá e você pode clicar quando acabasse
ser agora ou então tiver no computador a
braba ao lado não tem problema você pode
tá assistindo tanto eu agora como felipe
neto na outra alba na outra aba do lado
você tem democracia você pode fazer o
que você quiser
e quer mostra você essas roupas aqui no
são não mais não tá na direita tá na o
wi-fi aqui viu ó só vamos tá que cortar
aí olha para ele ver que eu tá
oi tá rosinha e agora olha aí ó
o igor fica espera aí a infinidade de
ovo
e qual é tem também
e é melhor olha aí a [ __ ] xiaomi esse
celular aqui ele tem cinco câmeras uma
resolução que não tem que no mundo
consiga dar 11 e acabar a qualidade
porque é bom demais mesmo e a incrível e
tem um link
e o banner foi feito com meu com esse
aqui o banner foi a foto do banda e foi
tirado com esse ela aqui meu irmão olha
lá no site está aqui na descrição do
vídeo você pode olhar daqui a pouco tá
bom a gente vai cantar uma bem difícil
agora oi
e o link está na tela aparecendo agora
na tela tá parecendo tá aparecendo bem
direitinho na tela aqui para quem quiser
tá bom para não ver que é minha mentira
ó
o que mudou no instante ó ixi quebrar a
eu aprendi
oi play
a luz verde
e enfim eu já mostrei no você aí meu
jovem que essa é a luz do meu quarto meu
amigo é a luizinho que vocês fica
olhando no meu stories fica sem entender
nada é só eu aqui ó vai ter que ter uma
national vem vermelho azul e por aí vai
e me bloqueia vamos lá galera
g1
e vamos lá presta atenção jeito é
difícil todo mundo lá
é bastante preocupado com meu pai é por
causa da gera só manda nudes não sabiam
que é um quintal vivem galera vitória
sobe quem te inspira tá com pneumonia e
a mais respeitada para chamar o médico
fica na sua não pode fazer uns negócio
aqui cantando código de dinheiro e
chegou segunda-feira é uma tristeza
rezam pela peça mais o fazem nada impede
o reggae vai 25 não fiquem sabendo isso
aqui dele começa a vergonha não vai ser
o cara levar ou do globo rural ajudava
meu pai trabalhar ele fica esses em
reclama jogar bola vamos soltar pipa já
que ele ganhou já pouco tá fazendo piada
do teto limpinha né mas que vendem na
rua do gol e vai fazer o mesmo que tu
quer brincando sua na câmara responsável
nenhuma você deixava de castigo se jogar
bola mandamento se liga que era para
cobrir todos os amigo companheiro para
que possa se toca que possa também é
esse cabelo para quem pode não é para
quem quer ser rico e é errado esse
cabelo não pode enviar para não dá para
fazer a parte de qualquer alta
a saída do glee pelo que representa que
eu procurava e não encontrava ninguém
não palavra de conforto era o sabe-tudo
de corda todo mundo pronto acabou na
boleta para ser na hora na hora do wi-fi
e falasse demais é porque meu irmão já
feito é ruim para gente vai sair de casa
aqui eles usam celular demais eu capa e
provoca multidão essa família infância
botão ponto tempo quando a gente
assistir atrás de gumball e acaba na
escola e a para tv ligar depois da tv
globo e eu me abusar a infância jorge
está presa um pc sai em nascer espera
seis anos o papa goiaba no pé da vizinha
minha mãe não sabia mas nada que fazer
prefeitura na rua era pequena também a
juntava toda galera uma realidade uma
cirurgia entregar pra galera apanhava
por dentro de obras de ali na esquina
aqui tá não isso não tem mais
o que tá mais alta queijo meu irmão
vagabundo ladrão rápido e essas hoje não
brinca de verdade só uma vez jet
estragar whatsapp verdadeira importância
que uma saudade coisa foi corrido correr
vai ter a cabeça aí no veículo mas o meu
amigo eu modelo que o riscar e o mesmo
usei um dente que ele parou olhou e
sorriu uma mulher na primeira da vida
grandemente foi passar lá amanhã para
mim dizer que ele como no presente e o
diabo ler a deixa vai cortar e o daí
entendeu tá roubando a bola essas
crianças de hoje só fazendo a luta do
quadro e sem liberdade de perdendo a
empresa de novembro bairro perdendo seu
tempo que o seu aperta brincar de pula
pula ninguém me segura aplica a
tendência também não devem ser
percebidos na rua se for apanhar um
tempo ficando ela não tem nenhuma comida
essa camisa que nós o maloqueiro era
mais ou menos arriscado madrugada era
melhor mas na verdade era sobre si mesma
coisa na minha vida que eu só falei que
não era para ter chamado a gente tem que
fazer
o brasil é campeão em uma campanha
chamada paulistão cada aqui tá levando o
dinheiro eu mando para ficar dependendo
chegar ficando com ele carregado soro
vai saindo para você ficar mais duas não
seja feita e o pior que fazer para
engravidar rápido tomar tando com a dora
aventureira mano pára pára pára pára
pára de fazer um ponto tempos quando a
gente assistir a tragam ball chegava na
escola se dá para te ver liga depois da
tv globo que eu ia almoçar sou da zona
então essa raiz e
o amor é o que dá ao vivo é isso aqui
que dá
o melado
quem é paulo é eu vi duas palmas
e três ai ai ai
a [ __ ] viu meu irmão já estamos aqui
na nos momentos finais ah tá faltando 20
minutos viu já já tem robson souza lá no
instagram do robson tem como botar a
roupa na tela agora do rota galera ver e
escrever arroba o robson sousa com s ou
com z robson
a manu ter sombra de dúvida com s ou com
z
ah tá não ele tá se preparando com
o robson o hum arroba o robson souza no
instagram vamos acompanhar live a partir
das 8 horas esse é um comediante
piauiense muito talentoso vamos dar
valor a galera na nossa terra vamos dar
valor à nossa galera tá 8:00 arroba o
robson souza no instagram dele tá robson
sousa com s vamos embora ainda até
música aqui ainda que
e eu tenho aqui paródias novas também eu
ontem eu fiz que para falar a verdade
não é uma paródia música original que a
beyoncé roubou essa música de mim
inclusive eu guardei até agora mas a
quarentena realmente fez eu não consegui
guardar esse segredo e revelar ao mundo
que você me plagiou infelizmente foi
isso que aconteceu com esse você sempre
o mesmo semana sair mandar lá eu conheci
nós da era criança mano
tô escutando as histórias que
aconteceram na minha casa né porque a
minha mãe era muito amiga da mãe dela e
aí saiu umas duas de um outro não é para
ir fazer uma ia fazer um negócio as duas
batendo papo uma coisa ficava nós lá e
abriu se observando fez a música mas eu
tenho a paródia original aqui a música
original para contar para vocês aqui ó
é que passem letra aqui
é mas eu acho que eu matheus gadelha me
mandou
sim ou não
a história
hum hum
é nós
o menino
é só tentando botar aqui a letra
primeiro aqui
é um abraço para quem está me assistindo
aqui agora sabe quem meu neto eduardo
sterblitch acabou de mandar mensagem
aqui eduardo sterblitch um beijo para
você meu amigo muito obrigado por tudo
na minha vida também porque você me
ajudou para [ __ ] também é ou não é
gente nossa inspiração quando a gente
era mais novo hoje você já está velho né
você é um ele foi lá em casa esses dias
é um cara que meu deus do céu
sensacional eu só tenho agradecer por
você existir na terra cara obrigado viu
tenha da hello vamos lá
bom vamos lá vamos lá dar um bora um
bora um bora um bora um bora aqui nós
estamos twitter em deixa eu dar uma
olhadinha aqui porque você sair 11 mil
tweets outra live aí no twitter você
pode continuar comentando lá qualquer
coisa
eu tava com meu primo jogando bola no
whatsapp ele falou vou andar de bike é
bem mais eu falei não dá certo em mim
uma surra da mãe sou iva ele falou
deixar de terror ela saiu foi trabalhar
minha bike então eu peguei uma corrida
com ele abordei e o controlar tetris mas
não dois comece a vera lá ela postar um
real eu falava o seu jovem ei só lembro
quando eu sobre isso a tua bike tá sem
frente eu já acordei no hospital e a
participar tio do mês a queda que eu
lembrei de hello seu cotovelo no joelho
eu queria me
eu já vou low-poo
e agora é
e essa história bem cedo
e aí
eu já te dizer uma coisa ninguém tá
doendo mais nada
com quem
e aí vai lá agora quanto é
de 20 mil primo rico acabou de para
colocar aqui para nós para nós estourar
papai para detonar o convite 19 simone e
simara mais gosto
oi tá fazendo contabilidade né pede
vamos ligar para logo aqui ao vivo você
não me dá bem era nina não vou ligar que
eu vou essa isso aqui
o marshmallow vai pintar o cabelo é o
diabo tá nem vendo cara da raça ou não
é preciso da sua filha bora logo você tá
em casa que você tá fazendo tratamento
da ou boa noite eu tô em live cara ao
vivo agora no youtube e
e aí
a estourada no youtube tampa com imã nós
acabamos de passar o jorge e mateus está
com 6 milhões de pessoas num simultânea
ao vivo no momento sai ser milhões entre
outros e milhões aí é loucura o brasil
tá não se fala em outra coisa hoje foi
no meu canal do youtube olha lá quantas
visualizações tá
e na tv e estourado macho ou para o
brasil que eu dou play on
oi pera aí que tá fazendo raiva do que
eu não tinha não foi mal eu tô na toca
do se aquilo ali acompanhando muito cara
você tá certo você tem que ficar aí
mesmo você e o tiago iorc escondido não
fala com ninguém porque o mundo aqui
fora tá muito doido tem noção não se eu
te dizer mas a meu intuito hoje aqui
quando ele te ligar é arrancar dinheiro
seu
e eu vi arrancar dinheiro seu para doar
para com 2019
e aí
ó ó se você não quiser dizer o valor não
precisa dizer se é só dar o ok que vai
dar do assunto a confirmado ou a galera
do youtube quer saber que a doação está
confirmada
ah tá
e se quiser dizer o valor também a
galera fica louca e aí por favor olha a
internet hein
o afe metei galera tudo bom postar ok
entendeu
e pode contar comigo o valor o valor
você ver um valor que você acha legal
justo aí pode levar eu vou-te detonar o
dinheiro para mim do jeito que tem 18
anos eu vi no fantástico uma vez então
assim você trabalha muito né eu acho que
não vai precisar eu ajudo e
e aí
e pode isso tudo passar cara eu quero
logo encontrar você que eu gosto muito
de você tem noção não tem saudade que
saudade que ele mora tão pertinho daqui
é muito perto você vai na casa da loc
bem meu nove minutos 8 minutos eu chego
lá quando tudo passar vai dar tudo certo
eu posso contar com você
é fechado manda um abraço para romana um
abraço no seu neném um beijo na tua
sogra também e tamo junto
é o diabo pera aí que alguém está claro
como é parei repente alguém me ligou bem
na hora você tem que ter um [ __ ]
que tá assistindo e liga para mim cara
liga olha eu de novo meu irmão do céu
caraca bicho é bem minha mãe
eu peguei minha mãe acabou ai não fala
mais não quando acaba mãe deixa eu fazer
aqui mãe é brincadeira é o número é de
fora 31350 não sei que não dá para saber
como é não fala aí o que que tava
dizendo eu tô botando perto do microfone
o seguinte mão
e pode passar isso aqui vamos se
encontrar
tô fazendo música fazer um vídeo hein
simplesmente aqui ó
e é nós feijão vai valeu falou que já tá
confirmado aí fala para ela que é isso
aí hein aí se arrombar na minha mão
porque pode ser quanto é vai ver o tanto
que eu vou botar
e eu morri eu achei vídeo muito pouco
o cabo investidor rápido
oi primo
o facetime eu quero ver no olho
é a minha tv é
eu ganhar vou ligar para simone como é
que você tá cara eu
o márcio já mandei os 20 mil comprar
cesta aqui deu três sextos é demais né
e eu acabei de ligar para o alok e o
alok do 350 mil ii
a mãe assim ah moleque acabar de pedir
um rápido ó aí aí ele pediu que eu não
troco ficou eu falei dá pra gente deu
para cá não tá bom então eu achei na
verdade eu acho que ajuda não pode não
pode ser grato é isso não pode ser grato
tem que ter sempre pensamento bom sempre
para cima porém está investindo
brasileiro que eu tenho que ir lá
e vamos investir no brasileiro
e aí pode ser então pa para comprar só
lá em casa dessa não semana vejam só lá
em casa lá em casa é um bicho é um monte
viu então pronto levei mais 10 na
insistência obrigado meu irmão um abraço
para você muito obrigado o thiago nigro
também primo rico é um cara que me ajuda
demais eu pergunto muito para ele porque
não adianta só ganhar dinheiro ali a
torto ea direito isso não tem que saber
onde votar porque senão realmente que eu
chego numa situação dessa como a gente
tá vivendo hoje a gente realmente passa
por um problema é não tiago então muito
obrigado por você tá ajudando a gente
aqui para você tá passando aqui comigo é
nós só seu amigo eu tenho no meu coração
tá tamo junto beijo para você mas sua
esposa aí tamo junto valeu
é mas 10 continuo primo rico
e a já temos mais aqui agora vamos ver
se do rio pena de ganso cara do outro
safadão perdeu a paciência com cara vou
fazer o seguinte
e outra coisa que a gente pode ajudar
aquilo antes que a gente termina e nós
estamos momentos finais única tá
girassol para galera uma coisa que
aconteceu girassol é uma música muito
impactante da minha vida né geração uma
música que assim eu não sei quando as
pessoas olhem para mim fala assim a esse
cara tá fazendo coisa errada esse cara é
isso esse cara é aquilo eu fico pensando
o quê que deus queria então quando ele
botou essa blusa na minha cabeça porque
eu escuto eu penso assim
que não é da minha cabeça isso você é de
fora isso é divino entendeu eu fico
pensando sabe às vezes eu penso esse
questionamento na minha cabeça e eu
falei com a priscila e a gente tá doando
todo direito autoral da música girassol
para combate ao convite 19 estamos aí
com 20 e tantos milhões de streams no
spotify só com essa música no youtube
tem muitas visualizações e vários canais
tudo isso é direitos autorais eu nunca
fui atrás de saber disso eu não faço
ideia de como faz para saber nem como
ganho dinheiro do almoço que se faz seja
assim porque eu tenho alguns amigos
compositores né por caio césar lá em
fortaleza walber cássio aí também tem a
nicki né a nicole megale lado só pessoas
que eu vou conhecendo uma na vida né e e
essa música foi muito parte aqui na
minha vida eu acho que a gente não tem
outro destino para fazer com o dinheiro
que se ganha com a música dessa do que
doar para ajudar algumas pessoas que
estão precisando aí nesse momento como
eu tô falando assim
eu penso muito na minha galera porque
enfim galera é como todo mundo vocês
pensam na galera de vocês onde vocês
mora você já ajuda acabar de você eu
gosto do lugar onde eu nasci entendeu
embora até algumas pessoas não gosta de
mim eu não me critique isso aquilo me
chame do que quiser não muda que eu sou
eu sou de um lugar aqui eu tenho orgulho
demais e eu quero ajudar lá olha aí ó
e no meio da girassol cara
e o que que a cachorra faz na mesa
girassol aqui cara ei amora amora em
e obrigado melhorar tem que pedir perdão
perdão desculpa jesus espera não não não
você tava rebolando a música girassol
aqui é [ __ ] aqui ó perdão por hoje
o rebolado girassol eu vou botar eu vou
botar no celular não é porque eu não sei
a letra não tá um abraço aí para todos
judite é o que érica dona sayonara que
estão em teresina piauí assistindo essa
live agora
é você que não conhece essa família do
joão um amigo meu que me deu casa me deu
comida me deu tudo quando eu sempre
precisei lá em teresina bob nunes
estamos junto é nós um beijo carinhoso a
todo mundo tá assistindo hoje a gente
vai ficando por aqui né mais ou menos eu
tinha muita história para contar muita
coisa para contar mais né realmente eu
preciso é de um palco preciso de um
palco para poder falar as coisa que eu
tenho vontade de falar eu sou sim cara
não adianta você pode falar o que quiser
pode mexer no a música tá muito morangos
que falando eu estou assim
olá eu sou assim
e é isso que eu sou é música eu falando
olha aí o impacto vou botar letra eu sou
ruim de letra mesmo e elton vasconcelos
acabou de arranjar uma tonelada de
álcool em gel uma tonelada de álcool gel
meu amigo e as vasconcelos lá de
teresina piauí vamos juntos leite
betânia três toneladas de leite amém
e a porta da igreja
e é como toda igreja não é todo crente
que gosta participam galera que mais
servnac segurança de fortaleza ceará
duas toneladas de alimento em segurança
para você são alimentos que vão chegar
em segurança porque a sebna que está
entregando se ela tá entregando meu
amigo são pessoas fortemente cansados
dois de mais alguém
[Música]
e já tá dando tempo e
o marcelo ferreira
é do que fora que é o que é
o mercado
o câmbio de moedas marcelo ferreira
acabou de doar quanto 35 mil reais
e nós estamos avançando aqui na doação
em galera temos tempo para você mandar
um alô para o kaká diniz para qualquer
pessoa para dizer quantas toneladas você
quer dar o quanto dinheiro você quer dar
não é possível que esse tanto de gente
não deu para juntar cada um no tanto e
ajudar a galera hashtag é bom mais
hashtag demora ajudar que tá lá no
interior do piauí viu
quem puder doar realidade vai ajudar
vamos lá vou botar leite aqui como eu
falei não tenho não não decoro letra nem
minha meu jovens negócio meu é ruim
é só até segurança muito obrigado por
você assistir até aqui deus abençoe você
e sua vida e que é agradecer aos meus
parceiros aqui a original cerveja
original obrigado rap ligado xiaomi tá
obrigado guaraná antarctica também por
tá aqui junto com a gente sempre
apoiando e tudo mais lembrando que eu já
dei o meu cachê dá uma campanha lá de
cima mas a logo da galera se alguém
puder doar nesse nesse é record que está
aparecendo aí que lá e vai ficar ao vivo
deve receber informações em
é nossa parceira também de distribuição
aqui para gente nossa parceiro de
internet de conexão oi muito obrigado aí
pela parceira de muitos anos quanto
tempo ele tá primeira empresa que
acreditou em mim de verdade assim para
me dar um incentivo só foi até saber que
eu podia mais que às vezes você precisa
ver se empurram para saber quatro vai
esperar cinco já né então mãe para o 4º
ano agora e vamos por cinco também
porque já estão a cidade de novo e mais
caro em que a galera tá vendo galera vai
cobrar vai lá se a vida fosse fácil como
a gente quer se o futuro a gente for
assim prever estaria agora tomar nunca
o significado de hello organizados como
eu nunca olhei carinha um abraço
apertado em meus avós queria eu te amo
aqui nunca pensei talvez é o que o que
jesus espera de nós eu quero ser curado
e ajudar por ao também eu quero ser
melhor do que eu nunca fui fazer o que
eu posso para mim ajudar desejo de
paciente com ver a jesus eu quero tava
até o calor do sol que eu esteja
preparado para quem me contour eu seja
todo dia vamos girassol e costa cruz
escuro e de frente brosu
e aí
é diferente dá um sonho de bom aí
a chave da sua se mas como a gente quer
se o futuro a gente pudesse prever eu
estarei agora tomando um café sentado
com os amigos em frente atender eu olhar
esas como eu não colei farinha um abraço
apertado em meus avós iria eu te amo
aqui nunca pensei talvez eu tenho
universo espera de nós eu quero segurado
e ajudar por aqui também eu quero ser
melhor do que eu nunca fui fazer o que
eu posso para mim ajudar
é justo e paciente começar a jesus está
difícil mas eu quero dar valor até o
calor do sol que esteja preparado para
quem me todos eu sei que todo dia vamos
girassol de costa do escuro e diferente
valor e frente do valor diferente falur
[Música]
e
e aí
é muito boa noite obrigado nossa
primeira live que foi até o fim
é muito obrigado deus abençoe você não
esqueça de deixar o like palma da
produção fala dos vizinhos e a vizinha
até o final ali rapaz ficou mesmo é cara
você que ele abusar porque talento vagar
né ele preparou um monte de coisa mas
quando ao treino do a salvação ao vivo
agora que você pancada que eu já vi a
casa dela ana hickmann está aqui ó
eu estou
[Música]
um mesmo isolado graças a deus você não
para graças a deus você não para porque
a gente se diverte com você a gente
anima esses dias que aí em casa os duas
ficar bem complicados todo mundo tão
preocupados com tanta coisa e com você
agora a gente consegue ficar mais
animada boas risadas é ruim obrigado viu
muito obrigado que deus abençoe você aí
seu marido você esteja bem na sua casa
tranquilamente todos os cuidados é isso
aí tamo junto sempre sempre comigo acho
que todo mundo agora a coisa mais
importante a união mesmo que à distância
virtual também para as pessoas de longe
né mas graças a deus a opção de mandar
uma mensagem não abriu uma
a chamada de vídeo está muito bom também
estamos juntos exatamente exame
excelente seja ajudar a gente aí também
e como é que é desculpa fala de novo e
me ajudar a gente aí lógico né que a
gente vai ajudar porque eu tô zerado
olha toda hora que eu abro direct era só
pancada toda hora aqui a galera é isso é
aquilo' teu coração mole eu vou ajudando
aí já tá já não conversa lá já deu um
tanto aqui eu queria saber quanto é que
você vai ajudar aqui a gente aqui espera
aí que eu vou chamar o homem dos
financeiros pega aqui aonde que você né
oi aline
com você tudo é uma casa né quiser
mandar um sofá desse aí eu liguei para o
luan santana deus em né liguei para o
eduardo costa de 80 lembrei é
e aí
e não estra vou que ele tá casa desse
tamanho que bota o wi-fi e
e olha eu tava eu tava dizendo para ela
que os valores reais no começo eu já
entrei dando sem aí eu pedi que alguém
cobrisse né e aí eu liguei para o luan
deu já deu mais né deus em também na
verdade eu igual não quis passar não
bateu o eduardo costa de 81 ló que deu
duzento eu tô querendo é bater eu adoro
eu até pego junto se você quiser eu boto
mais só bateu dele
e você pode dar 150 eu boto 200 eu boto
60 para cobrir o dele só um
o barbosa tem folha de pagamento dos
funcionários eu não consigo tudo mas os
funcionários esse momento aí com você
tão sempre não vão nada a perder com
você e sua família só dá certo a seus
funcionários aqui o meu aqui tá todo
mundo de graça não tá
a luta de graça aqui só na força do amor
saber não não sem problema eu tô aqui
para falar nada para brigar falar vai
conseguir quanto você puder ajudar ajuda
é ajuda vai ser bem interessado vai ser
vai ser sensacional vai chegar alguém
que precisa muito esse só de você tá
aqui é muitas pessoas para falar a
verdade ale não quer nem a conversa não
quer nem falar não quer ajudar não quer
nada você tá aqui falou comigo você anda
tô aqui falando comigo olha vocês estão
me ajudando sensacional porque sabe que
aquele deixa mal ale é porque a gente
conseguiu sucesso é a estabilidade e não
se sentir bem de como mundo tá sabe eu
sei que a minha família não vai ser
atingida não vai porque eu não vou
deixar sabe eu sei que o meus irmãos não
vão meus parentes não vão mas você fica
meio triste com o mundo como tá e você
me dizendo que você tá disposto a ajudar
meu coração já fica cheio de amor já
fica feliz demais meu irmão
bom dia
é de todo jeito no como você vai doar
pelo que tá aparecendo aí na sua tela
isso fechada com muito obrigado meu
irmão tamo junto é nós é
e é nós meu irmão obrigado um beijo a
você e a sua família que deus abençoe
você e a ana hickmann até quem faz
qualquer coisa quem faz para comida que
deus bote a mão mais sensacional para
fazer essa comida mais bem temperada que
seus filhos tem a melhor educação
melhores amigos nunca precise nunca no
que você vá resolver um problema para
eles que deus abençoar tamo junto é nós
beijo aqui ó
e amém meu pai tamo junto é nós valeu
mais uma nós conseguimos sabemos quanto
mais vai chegar aí a lapada viu que ana
hickmann é show de bola um abraço meus
amigos para luan murilo i
e agora vai começar ao vivo no instagram
de robson arroba o robson sousa com s a
live do show um pouquinho de comédia
para vocês aqui a gente vai estar
interagindo com vocês aqui também lá tá
não esqueça de seguir e é nós mais uma
doação a gente vai segurando tô
restaurante vai deixar tô nós vamos lá
[Risadas]
das essa aliança aí mas para nós é isso
aí cuidado e
oi boa tarde tu vai doar cara
e não não é o seguinte simone e simaria
é um é simone a outra simaria você o
cacá cada qual do seu entendeu cada qual
o seu coração sente se você não sente
nada pelo ser humano nem pelo brasileiro
você não deu esse negócio de coração
sempre é mentira viu
e eu vou segurando o negócio do bolso é
verdade viu é só tá segurando um
a barragem disse que é só é não eu que
meu coração não é não povo eu tô mas aí
o povo não precisa pagar não posta aí
nós aí ó é r$12 vai sair olha olha aí
[ __ ] pessoal ele detona mas não sou
ninguém né nossa meu arroba portaria e
você vai dar para gente ir
o rapaz que acaba e pegou de surpresa
que eu tô aqui de pijama mas eu olho ali
eu vou mandar mensagem para cá agora ele
vai dizer no ar vai mandar mensagem para
ela vai mandar mensagem vai mandar
mensagem dizendo apareceu sob jardim mas
vou estourar sério mesmo eu vou para
mijar na garrafa aqui pode não tá
pegando aqui no canto não né não posso
aí aí do luan toca uma música aí pessoal
entreter
e aí
bom vamos lá voltei para saber qual é a
doação doação ai ai groove é é
e aí
a coca é a hora da verdade de novo a
cachorra aí na frente cara
o que é isso essa cachorra fazendo nós
exibindo se exibindo sábado não aguentou
a gravidez não pode cachorro deve tá
muito magra essa cachorra não posso não
aguenta é a amorinha a
com a doação da simone só estava
esperando só isso aqui para gente serrar
oi quem é
e já está vendo esse cara aí cara é que
eu tô achando que você é
o caminho da doação
e aí
e você quer mais um
hummm hummm hummm hummm
bom vamos lá para cada cinco minutos que
sempre foi para lá deve ser aplicada
noção que você da carne junto com ela a
sua mãe revoltada
e a vontade que a record tá bom
tô esperando aqui a doação da galera meu
cash code você está em casa pode doar
igualmente o kaká diniz aqui mesmo na
pele em estado ruim então vamos lá que
eu já tô melado cachorra tava brincando
um negócio aí mesmo cheguei caxoeira
agora hora e nem vai me ver mais não viu
amora
é independente disso uma tonelada de
alimentos está doada para nós master
1000 de leite mais 130 mil reais e é
isso aí tamo junto um abraço na lula
murilo toda a galera que está me
assistindo meus amigos de bom jesus
piauí todo mundo do piauí está
assistindo agora todo mundo do amazonas
todo mundo de recife todo mundo que está
me assistindo agora eu esqueci de alguém
me perdoa tamo junto é nóis fica lá e
veio para vocês brincar lembrando que é
isso aí mesmo fizemos que a gente
treinou encontro de um falei lon tem uma
live quantas músicas tantas aprendemos é
isso vamos lá para o estudo robson souza
é nós se a galera tiver falando qualquer
coisa de você ou de mim cuide da sua
vida que vai ser muito melhor porque não
adianta tentar entender esse brasilzão
aqui não que aqui é esculhambado meu
amigo aqui é um país democrático que o
voto é obrigatório mas se você pagar
dois e 50 tá tudo certo já foi
e não adianta tentar entender ele tem o
brasil tamo junto é nós além das doações
que foram feitas vou fazer mais doações
não vou parar e vou perturbar do
whatsapp meus amigos para me dar
dinheiro para eu doar para esse negócio
aí viu tamo junto e nós empregado alok
obrigada ana hickmann obrigado simone
obrigado karine desligado todo mundo
obrigado a todo mundo que doou o rapaz
seu nome
o marcelo ferreira muito obrigado nossos
apoiadores aqui na live muito obrigado
tá a original cerveja original está com
a gente também rap também a para não
dizer que é a minha mentira porque podia
ser que fosse mas se eu botar iluminador
para mim lá em quando eu vejo tabaco
e vamos lá pode ir pode pegar mentira
o amor
e eu tenho essa no meu quarto tá gente
porque cada luz ficar conectado no
celular que vai mexer na sua própria
casa não todos vão mexer qualquer luz
que passar por perto tem conectada bom
olha aí azul era verde pera aí que eu
devo errei
e aí ó amarelo verde limão azul sabe
tocar alguma música para as cor que tu
sente
e vamos vamos começar dar como vamos
começar roxo vai hoje é [ __ ] né roxo é
uma cor muito negócio nada né não
laranja laranja é quente né
e olha eu valença eu acho que é isso aí
é isso aí muito obrigado não esquece
assistir no netflix adulto logo mais
estarei eu mais um show no netflix
também se a novidade para vocês tá muito
mais conteúdo do youtube muito obrigado
também é isso valeu faz o cruzeiro só
pra encerrar vai do que eu vai é
e para dia internacional moleque rouba o
robson souza oi oi
e aí